all right Simon now for the B wesbite  today's number 158,000 that's the number  of Olympic swimming pools you could fill  with the water needed to keep more than  800 California data centers cool so much  air conditioning yes California has more  data centers in any state not counting  in room server rooms and local  businesses according to tech consulting  company 451 research data centers aren't  the biggest water users in California of  course that would be the AG business but  the mid-size data center a mid-sized a  nurse enter for example would use  between 80 and 130 million gallons of  water every year that's equal to 100  acres of almond trees or three hospitals  two 18-hole golf courses in California  drought showing no signs of letting up